it has been about nine months since the
pandemic pulled clark county school
district students out of class
this morning ccsd and its biggest
teachers union announced a tentative
plan
to bring some children back to campus
hector mejia is live outside district
headquarters this this afternoon
with what they discussed hector
hey there john this is a major
development it gives us an idea of how
it's all going to play out well under
the plan ccsd schools will
reopen incrementally with the younger
students being the first returning to
campus
however there is no reopening date or
even a timeline to reopen and let's go
over some main takeaways from the
earlier meeting today
this is as you mentioned a tentative
agreement between the clark county
school district and the
clark county education association at
this point
students in grades pre-k through third
would be first to return to face-to-face
instruction
superintendent dr jesus dhara said
that's because
their team feels the younger students
need social interaction the most right
now
under the plan parents and teachers will
have the option to return
plus mandatory monthly testing for
teachers for cover 19
ppe and covet symptom screenings
contact tracing which will be helpful in
the event of an outbreak on campus
science and medical officials will be
the ones to determine
when the schools can reopen i asked the
superintendent if there's a threshold
that must be reached for them to go
ahead and make a decision to reopen
and here's what he said we're not only
looking at the covet
positivity we're also looking at our at
our mental health of our children and
our staff
we're looking at child abuse we're
looking at multiple
aspects there is no successful path
in this country to reopen these schools
under this pandemic it is really a trial
and error process
given that we have been following the
eighth largest school districts
and how they proceeded
that was ccea executive director john
villardita who believes the agreement
makes makes sense
because he said it's an incremental
approach he says it allows staff and
parents to see how
reopening on a limited basis with only
certain grades
would work at a time when the pandemic
transmission rate is rising
and again this is just a plan at this
time the clark county school
board of trustees are scheduled to go
over it and review it on january 14
and again still no date for when schools
could reopen reporting live outside ccsd
headquarters hector mejia
8 news now